he was beloved by many as Theo sipowicz
on the NYPD Blue but Austin Major's
tragic death at age 27 devastated his
friends family and the millions who grew
up watching him on TV on February 13
2023 TMZ reported that actor Austin
Majors died at the age of 27. according
to the publication he passed away on
Sunday February 12 while staying at a
homeless living facility located in Los
Angeles California an unspecified source
told TMZ that Major's death may have
come as a result of him ingesting a
fatal amount of fentanyl but this is
unconfirmed as of February 14 2023 the
autopsy is set to be completed soon with
the results said to arrive sometime
within the next few months coinciding
with the news of his death Majors family
released a statement that read he was a
loving artistic brilliant and kind human
being Austin took great joy and pride in
his acting career he was an active Eagle
Scout and graduated salutatorian in high
school he went on to graduate from USC
School of cinematic Arts with a passion
of directing and music producing they
also added that the entire family will
carry fond memories of their time with
him and that they will miss him forever
though his acting career wasn't long
Austin Majors racked up some
high-profile credits and entertained
audiences the world over before his
untimely passing he got his start in the
entertainment world as a child actor
starting out strong with a few
feature-length credits among his
earliest film appearances were Nevada
and the prince of air from 1997 and 2000
respectively in 2002 he even got the
chance to try out voice acting in the
Disney flop Treasure Planet where he
took on the role of a young Jim Hawkins
while he'd continued to appear at the
movies intermittently throughout the
remainder of his career there's no
denying that Majors television work is
what put him on the map most famously
Majors appeared quite frequently on the
police procedural NYPD Blue popping up
in 48 episodes between 1999 and 2004.
Theo Theo don't don't plop your mashed
potatoes all over the table come on just
eat up his work in the role of Theo
sipowicz the son of detective Andy
sipowicz paved the way for him to try
out other TV Ventures including ER and
CIS and Desperate Housewives however
none of these programs kept Majors
around nearly as long as NYPD Blue
ultimately did his final acting credit
is a season 4 episode of How I Met Your
Mother titled right place right time
rounding out a pretty solid yet brief
filmography following his time as an
actor Austin Majors decided to chart a
new course in life as mentioned
previously he made his way to the
University of Southern California where
he took up a major in film and
television production with a minor in
music on the side instead of using his
education to become a movie star or
return to being a frequent face on TV
Matrix chose to continue pursuing
different passions in the field of
entertainment Majors maintained a clear
interest in working in film and
television as evidenced by his LinkedIn
page where he expressed his desire to do
everything from directing to editing in
various kinds of visual media
furthermore Majors would also Embrace
his musical side he began producing
music under the name Pope and even had
some songs available on Spotify it was
clear that no matter the Avenue Austin
Majors had an insatiable desire to
follow and succeed at his creative
passions by family friends and fans
alike he will be sorely missed
[Music]
foreign